We're gonna play our own foodie detective game
with you both, it's a sense and edibility,
cute Jane Austen pun there with our Foodie Hour Challenge.
Whoo!
(audience applauding)
So we have our amazing foodie trophy at stake here,
(triumphant music)
(audience applauding)
and we need someone to host this game.
It's none other than Geoffrey Zakarian!
(audience applauding)
I don't know what four does.
(men speaking French)
A game show, I love this.
A game show, I love game.
Should I start?
Alright,
you take it away, yeah.
Okay, so what do we do?
Okay,
so the first challenge, okay.
This is gonna be a test of your foodie knowledge,
your senses and all of the things that you know, okay
and there are things that are three challenges
and they're all trending, are you ready?
Yes.
Okay, so the first challenge is in the cup.
You can look at it, smell it, then sip it
and write your answer on this board and let me see.
I love games.
And whoever's right
will get points toward this magnificent trophy, go.
See Ludo took the cup right off.
(audience laughing)
Write English.
Oui,
I was going to in French, yeah.
(audience laughing)
Are we ready?
Okay, I'm gonna let Natasha go first,
what do we have?
Natasha.
Cold McDonald's coffee, that's a song, oh, no.
Cold McDonald.
I think you're thinking of something else, darling.
I am.
Yeah.
Ludo?
Some iced tea, coffee, something.
Iced tea, coffee, so are you saying iced tea and coffee?
That's not a thing in America though.
It's not?
(audience laughing)
So just a cold coffee.
Although with food trends, you never know.
That's true.
So it's iced coffee?
Yeah.
Is that your final answer?
Okay.
Drew? Iced coffee with lemonade, ooh!
Okay, in your glass is orange juice and espresso.
Oh, no, you're not far, she's the closest.
Thank you, Ludo.
No, that's what I said.
So should we give her a point?
We're gonna give her a point, come on.
Thank you, thank you.
(audience applauding)
I'm like coffee and citrus.
Yeah, for sure.
That's a trend?
Believe it or not, this trend's popped up on TikTok.
People either love it or hate it.
Alright, let's go, are you ready for the next one?
(audience applauding)
Put on your blindfold please.
Blindfolds.
Okay, this is gonna test your feel and feel it, then eat it,
then write down your answer on the board.
Oh, we get to eat it?
You get to eat it.
No way!
I mean, we have to eat it? (crunching)
It's tough, right?
Garlicy.
It sounds like
it's something that you would know, right?
Oh my God, what?
Whoa.
Huh? Ah-huh.
The blindfold's throwing my equilibrium off.
You okay?
Can I take off the blindfold, right?
Yes, of course.
I'm just really trying to figure it out.
I love being in charge. Okay, you ready?
You're very quick. What is that?
Oh God, I'm sorry,
I don't know if I was supposed to show.
Well, yeah, you can show, it's okay.
I have fried cheese.
Fried cheese?
Orange cheese.
Fried orange cheese. (laughing)
Yeah, fried orange cheese, orange.
Oh, this is so much fun.
This is a new food dark show I think right here.
Yes?
I did not like it at all.
Okay, you didn't like your first one?
You're a hard customer.
Fried chex mix with cheddar.
I don't know.
The answer, (clears throat) pasta chips.
So it's pasta.
Wow.
(audience applauding)
Pasta chips?
Pasta cooked, blanched right there, take a look
and tossed with olive oil and a little Parmesan.
I knew this was a TikTok thing.
But it's good, it's tasty, no?
Okay, so it's slightly cooked?
Yes.
Oh, it's actually cooked?
Oh, you bake it in the fryer.
Okay, okay, oh, wow.
(audience applauding)
So I mean,
this trend on TikTok, you ready?
It got 1.1 billion ticks.
Wow!
Okay, third challenge, you ready?
This is fun, okay.
You have a candle in front of you,
your job, you are lighting it.
One of them is a candle actually
and the two of them are a candle and one is a cake.
So light what you think is who's who, are you ready?
So Drew, do you think this is a cake or a candle?
Cake.
Wow. Okay, write it down.
Oh, sorry.
(audience laughing)
Ludo, are you having a little trouble
with the lighting over there?
Yes, I'm good.
So are you just gonna do one?
Yeah.
You need help, Ludo?
No, ca va.
Gateau.
Gateau, which means cake, cake, cake.
Natasha.
Andle.
(Ludo speaking French)
Mine's different.
Ludo hasn't even played any of the games right.
Ah!
Oh, c'est gateau!
Whoa!
(Ludo speaking French)
(audience applauding)
Cake!
Amazing!
(Ludo speaking French)
Gateau and you have a real candle.
(cake slice thudding)
(audience laughing)
Alright, so we have two winners.
(audience applauding)
I'm giving it up to Natasha.
(Natasha laughing)
Let me award this beautiful, wonderful trophy.
Beautiful, it's yours, you're playing with that.
Oh!
Yeah.
(audience applauding)
Natasha, yeah.
Natasha.
Do I have to check this at JFK?
Yes.
Yeah, you need to.
(audience applauding)
Thank you, Natasha, thank you, Ludo.
Thank you.
Well done.
Thank you, Ludo Lefebvre, Natasha Leggero.
"Rat in the Kitchen" airs Thursday on TBS at 9/8 central.
It is so fun, it is so good, get in that kitchen.
(melodic upbeat music)